[Music]
what's up my name's samuel leaves right
now we are at the development
deep dive and i'm teaching a small group
of budding property developers
and my intention is for them not to
become financially free my intention is
them to become
property millionaires millionaires in
the next 12 months it's a big ambition
i'm not guaranteeing it
but we'll see what we can do if you
haven't got a patch
if you know how to find deals you have
to find opportunity because this is not
this is not right move by the way folks
the way that we find our deals we don't
go on right move and look for
opportunities you know we've got a lot
of ways we find deals
if you want to become a millionaire and
some of you might already be old enough
but if you want to come
in there in property you start from not
much but you're already a millionaire if
you want to become a multi-millionaire
you need to be i think
a little bit crazy
i think you need to have dj i think
okay a lot crazy okay so they'll think
you're all crazy i'll think you're a
little bit crazy
you need to have the g
the i don't give an f g when you're
asking people
for millions of pounds
when you've got ideas and you're saying
hey i've got this deal and they go okay
well
what's your final speed you know i want
100 grand finals today
you're going to feel like i'm not really
worthy of this
you know what what what are people going
to think about this
and you just actually you know i'm going
to think a lot bigger and i don't really
care
if you can't get finance let's say
you're um for whatever reason you're not
qualified and eligible to get finance it
doesn't matter and the reason it doesn't
matter
is because most deals are only forms of
joint ventures anyway
most invaders joint ventures so let's
say you're absolutely
you know you're you're broke you haven't
got access to finance
your credit's terrible you have got no
experience as a developer and it's just
like oh man i've got nothing
well it doesn't matter because you can
join ventures first thing about joint
ventures
is every joint venture is different and
a joint venture is a complete blank
piece of paper
now in terms of property pretty much
everything that you want to happen
can be brought into a contract hate
whatsoever
pretty much everything that you want to
happen in property can be put into a
contract
and this is the thing that just just
freaked me out over time i remember
calling my sister but i'm like hey can
we do this
and the answer is pretty much always yes
you can and there's a technical name for
it it might be a
a lockout agreement an option agreement
or this about the other but a joint
venture group is a black piece of paper
so
the traditional way to structure a joint
venture agreement is like this
you set up a company
this is the traditional way and the
company has got
two types of shares it's got a shares
and it's got b shares and just from the
record
this is not you don't have to do this
this is not this is how every joint
venture is structured this is just how
traditionally a joint venture is set up
so let's say me and earl
want to go into business together okay
and i i'm like oh
i've got a really nice commercial site
i've agreed to buy it for a hundred
grand
so so let's say me and i want to do a
business together do a joint venture
together i might say oh
i've got a commercial block it's a
hundred grand
i want to split it up into apartments
it's gonna cost me a hundred pounds to
do that
200 grand all in but then the gross
developer base 300 grand there's a
hundred thousand pound profit
brilliant your deal i might say to evans
evans
you put the money in i want you to put
the hundred grand in
we'll get development finance on the of
the hundred grand to do the conversion
that's going to be easy
and steve's going to talk about this if
you buy the if you buy the land
or the building initially for 100 grand
it's going to be very easy
to get a hundred thousand pounds finance
and the reason it's going to be easy is
because
the finance company is going to be able
to put a charge
on the property that you own outright
okay does this make sense questions
really simple like
like if you're buying a property if you
leverage too much and steve's going to
go into the figures and talk about
all the ins and outs but let's say let's
say you leave bridge the figures as much
as you can
and you buy this property but you only
put in a tiny little percentage of your
own money
and then you're trying to get
development finance the finance company
is going to go hold on a minute
you don't own that because that's not
your money that's so-and-so's money so
if you want us to
lend you money to do the development
work
they're gonna be a bit uncomfortable so
they're gonna not give you as much if
you say
i own this outright oh by the way the
gdv
is 300 grand i own this 100 grams you
can have no
issues with a bridging company just
going oh we'll pay for the whole lot
we have no issues however how does this
help with the joint venture
structure so i'm going to sell my
company i'm going to say to evans evans
i need your money buddy
we're going to put your hundred grand to
buy the property
we're going to use a bridge in finance
to do the hundred grand development
finance
we're gonna push the value up to 300
grand and that hundred grand profit
we're going to split 50 50 between you
and i
i'm gonna put in nothing you're gonna
put in a hundred grand
the bridging finance company is gonna
put in a hundred grand they're obviously
going to charge interest
so they're gonna have to deduct their
interest payment out of the profit which
might make the hundred grand suddenly
85 grand no problem
i'm putting in no money i'm getting half
of half of the profit he's putting in
his money he's getting half the profit
that's what it looks like on paper how's
it structured as a joint venture
agreement well if i say to evans
evans i want to borrow the man evans is
going to say
no work no worries well let's have a go
too fast
everybody's going to say no worries i'll
enjoy i'll enter the money but the
problem is
what's my guarantee that i'll get it
back
evans is going to want a charge on the
property what's the problem with evans
having a charge on the property the
problem is then when you try and get the
development finance
there's a charge already now now there's
a second charge
and a second charge lender is going to
be a bit more
skeptical so instead of him lending me
the money
what i'll say is i was like evans let's
set up a company we'll call it evans and
samuel limited
okay brand new company which will set up
to their company's house
which will cost us 15 pounds and we can
do instantly it will take 24 hours and
when at the code
we'll have the little company number we
can pay an accountant it's gonna cost
about a hundred pounds
to buy an account to set this up we
could do yourself in 15 pounds
so we'll set up this company me and
evans
evans is going to then put 100 grand
into that company now evans isn't going
to want that company to be
50 million 50 here because if everyone's
putting 100 grand
and it's half my company effectively
everyone's just giving me 50 grand
everything's gonna want to just give me
50 grand in case i then go actually
we lost the deal but at least they got
50 grand for free
so what evans is going to want to do is
he's going to want to go hold on hold on
if we set up a confidence 50 50 and i'm
putting in all the money
we need two shares we need a shares and
we need b
shares and an shares are going to be
owned
100 by evans
[Music]
and b shares are going to be owned
50 50 evans
samuel i i don't know by the way this
stuff
is really basic and i'm teaching you to
suck eggs right now or if this is
or if this is like new to you but i'll
tell you one thing it's very very very
important it's very
um it's very important you get this so
is this something you guys are already
familiar with
no no
cool fine because if if if it's uh so
you already know go real fast if it's
not
i'll go a bit slow okay so evans now
puts in 500 grand
now and shares
are the current money in the in the
company so evans is always going to have
that hundred grand that's his so when
the deal finishes
and we and we get that our money b
shares
b shares is the money that's made as a
result
of the hundred grand b shares in any
future profits of the company
a shares is the money that went in
what that means is that means if the
company goes on to do let's say the
company or the property it does
really really well and isn't making a
million pounds that's 50 50.
if we decide not to sell if we decide to
refinance and we rent the property out
all of the rent is split 50 50 because
that's
profit moving forward but then when we
sell
evans gets his gets his hundred grand
back because he always owns that hundred
grand
so from from the point of view of evans
or the person's putting the money in
they're not risking anything unless you
mess up the deal because they're just
going oh i'm gonna put 100 grand in
but that 100 is mine but the companies
50 50 are from the b
shares so you need an accountant that
knows how to set this up
and by the way like you're on the
mastermind you're going to be sitting
with my account having dinner with my
account
this will this will become like child
life this is very very straightforward
so that's joint ventures now if you
don't
set up do this so sometimes what i will
do
is i will have a company all right a
limited company
that's not my company this company is
owned by someone who's not met
right then we find a development
opportunity right commercial resident
whatever
this company is not my company i have
many many many deals whereby
this person will come to me and they'll
go samuel i need some money
can you put the money in and i don't
want to set up a company
i don't want to set up a company with
them for whatever reasons my accountant
tells me not to so what i do instead
is i give my money to the company let's
say it's a million pounds
i give my million to the company the
company buys the property it's not in my
name
now is that risky well the answer is no
it's not risky
and the reason it's not risky is because
it's not different from when a bridging
company
gives money it's not in their name but
they're still getting
an agreed return so in many cases
what i'll do is i'll give you the
million pounds you then
the company you know to me buy the
property
you develop it you do all you want
however i put the money in
and i want 50 50. but rather setting up
a company what you do is you have
a joint venture agreement
okay which which specifies exactly what
the terms are namely
it could be i put the money in i'm going
to get 50
of the profits it could be in the
with the land deal it could be i put the
money in i'm getting 66 i'm getting 66
of the profits so we have a very
carefully drawn
agreement by a solicitor which again on
the map on the mastermind forum you'll
meet my solicitor and i'm doing it with
him
and you'll study these agreements and
this
agreement okay so when we have the
no words when we have the the title
deeds
and i on the title dudes yes or no
[Music]
i am now i'm not on the title beats as
the
owner i'm on the title deeds
as the joint venture partner so what
they'll be is there'll be a charge
and a restriction
on the on the property which says that
this person or this company
although it owns the project it cannot
sell
without it going through a solicitor and
the solicitor
has to comply with the joint venture
agreement and the joint venture
agreement says i'm getting 50
oh and before we sell any money
i need to get my million pounds back
first before anything and then after
that i'm getting 66
50 or whatever we agree that's on the
joint venture agreement and the joint
venture agreement is literally black and
white
on the title deeds to the property so so
that's another way you can do a joint
venture so if i say
if i say to you hey you want to put some
money into a deal
you might say all right cool now we
could do it the other way around you
could do it like this
you could say ben might say i've got
i've got
500 grand i'll put them on the end and
i've got no problem there then
let's do it like this you as you're
putting in all of the money bank
let's set up a company we'll call it
purple rain limited doesn't matter what
it's called
and it's your company ben your company
you're going to put the 500 000 pounds
into
your own company i found this deal
it's you know i found the project you're
going to buy it
you're going to buy it through your
company you own all of the shares in the
company
the company has nothing to do with me
other than the fact
that i am going to register and joint
venture agreement on the title deeds and
the joint venture agreement is going to
say
that when you sell any profit i'm taking
50
now that way from the joint venture
partners agreement from perspective he's
thinking
i'm putting all the money in it's in my
company it gives
investors security because sometimes if
you say to an investor can you give me
500 grand
you give me half a million quid and say
whoa but if you say hey
let's set up a company that you're with
the director of and you put the [ __ ]
queen your own company
and you buy the property in your own
company and all i want is i just want to
make sure i get 50
of the profits so whenever we'll have an
agreement which will tell us this step
to put on the target is
that's another way you can do it but as
i say the most common way
is to set up a joint company and have a
shares and b shares
and it all depends on what you offer
from a position of what you're what's
the most tax deductible i'm not an
accountant so i can't i don't
i don't know if you're different tax
affairs but these are the ways to
structure joint ventures
but the important thing is that you know
about this so that when you're asking
people to join venture with you whether
you're asking for money whether you're
asking for deals
you need to know how this works
development deep dive two days learning
about commercial to residential
about land acquisition about title
splitting it's been a fabulous due date
i want to see you here too